qu'est-ce que vous avez laissé à paris
rien rien du tout rien aucun regret au
cours des années 70 quelques milliers de
jeunes citadins quittent la ville pour
s'installer à la campagne
dans la foulée de mai 68 il rêve d'un
retour à la nature
ils apprennent le dur métier
d'agriculteur à 1000 mètres sur le
causse
saison après saison ils ont appris la
longue patience que les paysans savent
depuis des siècles la poussière de l'été
la ruine à restaurer la morsure du froid
la terre à mettre en valeur
mais la vraie difficulté c'est la
rencontre entre deux univers pour les
paysans locaux
ces nouveaux venus sont avant tout des
hippies bas on leur reproche d'être des
envahisseurs surtout et ensuite d'avoir
des notions sur la propreté qui sont un
peu comme moi je pourrais dire qu'ils
sont un peu en marge
alors ces deux mondes vivent le plus
souvent les uns à côté des autres sans
trop se mélanger des conflits éclatent
parfois à qui appartient la terre pour
ce nouvel arrivant par exemple elle
appartient à celui qui la cultivent pas
à celui qui la possède
s'il avait voulu exploiter j'y serais
déjà
il ne l'aurait pas laissé de simplement
ce qui fait qu'il a annexé quelques
maisons c'est vrai qu'on a laissé
quelques traces parce qu'il fallait
qu'on vive ces terres étaient en friche
où elle a travaillé
après une expérience d'une dizaine
d'années le constat de ces néo ruraux et
souvent amers si certains ont réussi à
faire souche pour d'autres il reste des
étrangers doublement des ip ou on l'est
autant pour les gens qu'on a quitté le
milieu sociologique qu'on l'a quittée
que pour les gens qu'on a trouvé ici au
cours des années 80 cette vague de
retour à la terre ce tarif
remplacé par une nouvelle tendance des
néoruraux qui recherchent l'air de la
campagne tout en gardant leur travail en
ville
[Musique]